i like to choose to live my life in a
way where
i want to be weight free selena gomez
her ex
justin bieber and his wife haley bieber
are
so over that whole selena vs haley thing
and now a source is opening up to e.t
explaining that they find that narrative
exhausting he's just really sweet he's a
good kid
he's a good part and i love him
a little background last week justin
called out an instagram
user who encouraged selena fans to bully
his wife
haley posting a lengthy message on his
insta story that read in part
quote it is extremely hard to choose the
high road when i see people like this
try and rally to gather people to bully
the person i love most in the world
it is not right now e.t source says that
selena
justin and haley are all tired of the
two ladies being pitted against one
another
quote it's exhausting for everyone and
they just want people to move on so they
can move on too and not focus on any
further negativity or past situations
[Music]
so now fans are wondering where exactly
does the lose you to love me singer
stand
when it comes to romance well you might
have heard rumors that she's dating nba
player jimmy butler
but a source tells e.t that cell isn't
jumping into anything serious right now
i'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel
like all right what could i be better at
where could my confidence be stronger
quote selena has enjoyed hanging out
with jimmy but she is keeping her
options open in terms of guys
she is comfortable dating but also
comfortable being single
she's not rushing into anything
whatsoever selena is focusing on what
makes her happy and what feels good to
her
whether that's a relationship or not i'm
getting to do things that i'm passionate
about with the people that i love
so what is selena looking for in a
potential new boot
our source says she wants what we all
want a guy who is confident
supportive smart funny trustworthy and
reliable
i think it is important to kind of go
through your life the way you want and
i like to to come at things with my best
that's all i know how to do is just give
my best